hey - gogo here and I just want to work
me to another ColdFusion video and today
I'm actually gonna show you guys how to
get this on your home screen it's some
interesting stuff enjoy guys
you are watching cold piston TV every
time you take your device out of your
pocket the lock screen is the first
thing you set your eyes upon why can't
lock screens be simple easy on the UI
and practical at the same time let's
change that now the lock screen you are
about to make is based off widget Locker
swipe to the right to access key apps
and swipe to the left to get straight to
the camera it's practical without the
clutter let's get started first of all
you're going to need to download some
apps these apps all free from the Play
Store the first app is a widget Locker
the actual basis of the lock screen the
second app is ultimate custom widget
this is where the large square clock
comes from to get the actual clock skin
type in aim 7 in google play and
download as indicated and finally we
need to download minimalistic text for
the written clock underneath the square
clock so once you've downloaded and
installed all those apps open up widget
lock click on the top right and you'll
enter the menu within widget Locker go
to the first category buttons and inputs
under this section make sure these two
options are selected exit out of that
and click on look and fill all the
remaining steps within widget locker
will be within the look and feel
category go into look and feel make sure
alternative wallpaper is unchecked and
then click on background tint adjust the
background tint as follows
this just makes for better readability
on lighter backgrounds exit out of the
background tint and below it click on
layout for the layout make the grid
twelve by twelve for the finest level of
adjustment if you want your lockscreen
to operate in landscape you can click on
screen orientation adjust it from there
and finally make sure you tick these
last two options so once this is done we
long press on the home screen and it's
time to add our widgets so you scroll
down to widgets and click on
minimalistic text and then we'll just do
a four by one horizontal layout
just click create and within millaa
millaa stick text make sure the
background option is unchecked after
that go to the textile tab along the top
and click on the accented text make sure
bold is unchecked so once you click OK
and exit the app you should have a clock
exactly like mine so it's time to move
on to the big square clock so once again
click on the home screen widget and do
the 4 by 4 layout click on create' and
scroll down to whichever clock you want
I'm just going to use the white one and
you can resize as desired so we're
almost there the last part is that
unlock slider
to get the unlock slider we long press
and then click on custom slider click on
the last option get themes with the XDA
in brackets open it with your favorite
browser you'll be greeted with this
webpage click on the middle link as
indicated to simply download the file
there might be a few pages that you have
to go through but the final link is in
mediafire don't worry the file is
completely safe on the final mediafire
link when prompted complete the action
with widget Locker once it's downloaded
go to your notification bar and click on
the file this will open up widget Locker
and then you have your custom slider
right there uncheck show clock and click
done on the top left now you have your
custom slider all you have to do is just
resize and place it where you want by
the way if any of you are new here and
you're wondering about this 3d interface
I'll leave a link in the description
below so you can follow the tutorial for
that so there you have it a nice clean
minimalistic lockscreen that looks great
and is functional too thanks for
watching guys hopefully you've learnt
something if you liked it please give
the video a thumbs up and even subscribe
if you want and if you know anyone
personally that's actually just sick of
the way their phone looks pass this
video on to them I'm sure we're helping
out cheers guys and I'll see you again
soon for the next one
are you thinking oh yeah and if any of
you guys want some lockscreen
notifications I'll leave a bunch of apps
in the description below enjoy